欸，你聽說過賣「捕食者尿液」這種產品的嗎？聽起來就蠻特別的。
捕食者尿液？喔，你是說那家賣給獵人，用來掩蓋人類氣味的公司對吧。這我最近看到一個很有意思的案例，顛覆我很多想法。
怎麼說？我猜啦，不就是把產品賣給更多獵人，或是開發新的狩獵產品嗎？
其實，故事不是這樣。這家公司一開始在緬因州賣捕食者尿液給獵人當作掩飾氣味的產品。結果有一天，一家園藝店下了一筆遠超乎尋常的大訂單，時間點還是在春天，根本不是狩獵季節。
等等，這裡我有疑問。這麼奇怪的訂單，一般公司不就直接處理掉、照常出貨嗎？誰還會特別去追問？
這就是重點了。那位創辦人，他當時每筆訂單都還是自己處理的，所以這種異常的數量和季節讓他覺得不對勁。他就打了一通電話去問那家園藝店。
一通電話？然後呢？發現什麼大秘密了嗎？
這通電話揭露了一個驚人的事實：園藝店的顧客根本不是獵人，他們是園丁，買這個產品是要用來驅趕兔子，讓兔子以為附近有捕食者，這樣就不會來吃他們的萵苣。
喔，這個做法很有意思！所以說，同樣的產品，功能完全沒變，但使用情境和顧客群體卻完全不同了？
沒錯，而且這還不是他們一開始設計產品的目的。他們原本是為獵人設計的，沒想到園丁們自己找到了第二種用途。
這點其實不容易做到，很多公司一發現顧客「亂用」產品，第一反應是去糾正顧客的行為，要他們按照說明書來。
的確。但這個案例，還有像是諾和諾德的Ozempic和Wegovy，都證明了反過來做，反而能開創出全新的市場。Ozempic原本是糖尿病藥，但許多患者發現它有減重效果，諾和諾德並沒有去禁止，而是順勢開發出Wegovy這款減重藥。
所以這家賣狐狸尿的公司，也因為那一通電話，開創了第二個事業線，針對園丁市場推出驅趕害蟲的產品？這個模式撐得久嗎？成本划算嗎？
原文有提到，他們後來花了四十年，從家庭農場的小事業發展成更廣泛的野生動物驅避產品線，從雞舍到菜園，甚至針對老鷹都有不同的解決方案。這就說明了，一旦你真正理解顧客的需求，市場潛力是很大的。而且，初期成本其實就是一通電話，非常低。
我想到一件事，如果我是創業者，遇到這種「異常訂單」，我可能也只會當成個案處理。我要怎麼像這個案例一樣，從中找到商機？
他們的做法提醒我們，任何出乎意料的訂單或使用方式，都應該被視為重要的市場情報。尤其是那些不符合你預期模式的訂單，通常裡面就藏著你還沒發現的顧客需求。
那如果我是個上班族，這對我能有什麼啟發？我好像沒辦法去打電話給客戶問他們「為什麼要這樣用我的報告」。
當然不是要你打電話，但概念是共通的。你可以多留意同事或主管「怎麼用」你的工作成果。如果他們總是把你的報表重新整理成另一種格式，你是不是可以主動問問看，他們真正需要的是什麼？或許你以為提供的是「數字」，但他們其實需要的是「結論」。
嗯，有點懂了。就是不要只看表面，要深入去了解對方行為背後的原因。
對，而且原文也提到，不要急著用你上次成功的解決方案來套用在新問題上。像他們後來發現，驅趕哺乳動物和驅趕鳥類需要的技術是完全不同的，因為這些動物感知危險的方式不一樣。
聽起來，這好像也提醒了我們，有時候最有效的解決方案，其實就在最直接、最原始的溝通裡。